let's leave that one there and shift to
the elderly gentleman pretending to be
president of course I'm talking about
Joe Biden uh don't uh worry about Joe
that's at least what Nancy Pelosi say in
these days he's now his grandfather he's
mostly grandfatherly and we should
appreciate that I want to ask
um speaker Pelosi about 2024 you talked
a lot about President Biden's uh
successful presidency so far all the
points on the board it's a long list I
think arguably uh objectively one can
say he has accomplished a great deal
maybe even historic proportions
um but there's uh the question I have
for you as a
um honoree on the very first 50 over 50
list with Forbes and know your value a
lot of people are talking about the
president's age as a factor in this
especially Republicans
um what do you make of the criticism the
president is getting that he's too old
to have a second term I think the
President should embrace his age his
experience what he has the knowledge
that he brings to the job
they're putting aside uh Nancy Pelosi
for just a moment the way that Mika is
tickling his old balls I'm sorry for the
imagery could really make you barf oh
you like that one like that one they
were a little more uptight over there at
the daily wire but but don't take my
word for any of people might be watching
going Dave you're always hitting him on
his age it's just too much well Biden
did manage to fall asleep while talking
to the Israeli President we brought
Israelis and Palestinians together at a
political level
go ahead and roll strong yes and as I
Farm to front
Knowles
the issue is not the age the issue is
not the I'm with Aristotle I think age
and maturity that's good with age comes
wisdom Reagan was old Trump is old the
problem is that the man doesn't function
he was never the sharpest tool in the
shed going back to 1972 when he entered
the Senate and things have gotten
dramatically worse in recent years even
since he left the Obama White House and
if you just see it absolutely everywhere
it's constantly on show so the libs have
tried to resurrect this idea of a virile
Biden they used to do it with dark
Brandon memes now they're doing it with
this leak this leaked report to axios
that Biden he's yelling at his staff and
he gets into the Weeds on the details
and all the policies it's total BS the
guy is asleep the guy's not only asleep
most of the time he's asleep most of the
time that we see him on camera so so
he's declining cognitively and in the
polls this is also why you see a Gavin
Newsom waiting there in the wings
the question right now is who's going to
decide the nominee first the Republican
party or the Democrats yeah I think
that's well said uh Brian what are you
making this thing I agree with Michael
it's not this is not making fun of
someone because of their age he could be
five years older and if he was competent
even if I disagreed with him this would
not be about age this is about literally
falling asleep in front of the president
of another country this is a problem
yeah so look is commander-in-chief your
support your preeminent role in this
country in fact in the world given what
we are as a nation is to protect and
defend and let's think about this from
the perspective of our foreign
adversaries China Russia others even our
allies in Europe they're looking at this
guy and they're saying I don't know if
he's going to make it to tomorrow
the age issue really is as Knowles just
said it's a cognitive concern